This video is brought to you by wix.
How do y'all jared?
Here we are stupid,
excited about red dead redemption.
Two,
so to celebrate it coming out,
we wanted to break down numero uno and
ask what does it all mean just like an
older brother,
grand theft auto grand theft horse takes
a satirical look at American culture
despite being set over a hundred years
in the past,
but above all else,
red dead redemption is a commentary on
our relationship to it,
and if civilization was even worth all
the trouble.
So saddle up for this wisecrack edition
on the satire of Red Dead Redemption and
of course spoilers ahead for a game
that's eight years old.
First a quick shout out to our channel
sponsor wicks and our last video I told
you about some cool community stuff
we're doing with their website building
platform.
Now we're happy to unveil our first site
where you can vote on what we should
cover in an upcoming episode of our
movie podcast.
Show me the meaning.
Stick around until the end to check it
out.
And now back to the show.
To Recap,
red dead redemption tells the story of
John Marsden and Oge cowboy trying to
become a productive member of society
until it gets blackmailed by the
government,
forcing him to hunt down his former gang
members Marston.
Then Moses on down that lonesome trail
into his past seeking redemption.
See what you did though,
Rockstar so he can get back to that
simple farm life so far.
Classic West,
the game even uses all the classic
cliches,
expensive vistas,
quickdraw,
shootouts,
literal cowboying,
gambling,
Mexican and native Americans getting
shot by a dude called John and horse
riding.
Lots of horse riding.
So with all this direct Oman,
where does the satire come in?
Like GTA?
Much of red dead set higher comes from
the game's huge cast of non playable
characters who at first may seem like
stock Western archetypes.
There's Jenny,
the good Christian girl in the opening
scene,
do you,
unless innocent receives communion,
they're destined to go to him,
hardly seems fair.
Or Sam Odessa,
who's on a journey to the promised land
of California or old Billy West,
who asked you to collect flowers for his
beloved wife,
but whereas your traditional Western
would use these tropes to tell wholesome
tales of faith,
hope or love,
red dead redemption has other ideas.
You leave Jenny to die of exposure out
in the desert.
Sand becomes a paranoid drunk and then
you find his body torn apart by
vultures.
Oh,
and billy's loving wife.
You collected all those flowers for.
She's actually a rotting corpse.
Yes.
You don't look a day over 30 ma'am.
Or You have a character like Louisa and
idealist with naive notions of a
glorious revolution and a free Mexico
who gets unceremoniously shot dead in
the middle of a mission.
And then the man she claims to be
engaged to can't even remember her name
was Shay is your peasant girl wife to
be.
Oh yes,
of course.
She will have a day named after day that
we said what?
Oh yes.
I knew it allowed as well.
This puts rdr firmly in the camp of
something we've talked about before.
The Post Western,
a kind of anti western that subverts the
image of the old west as it's
classically depicted,
the game pits kind old men and young
maidens against the harsh realities of
the lawless west or feeling how easily
these idealists in romantics were
crushed by the brutality of the great
western expansion,
evenly twisted idealism of the
tyrannical Mexican leader Colonel Again
Day.
Oh,
I fight to help them find themselves to
save them from themselves,
ends rather abruptly,
but as the characters who survive that
provides the games most scathing satire.
The characters that survive tend to be
your allies and they will suck except
Bonnie.
She's fine,
but the rest are largely selfish and
unsympathetic.
Leading us to wonder who we're supposed
to be rooting for.
Most of them won't even assist you until
they've been assisted by you.
Take Marshall Johnson.
He has some pretty fluid ideas on how to
police the town of Armadillo in an early
mission,
hopefully call the political realities
and Armadillo.
He reveals a conflict of interests to
put it lightly between public safety and
big business.
I've got the railway.
The people are paying my salary,
trying to get me to turn a blind eye to
them,
burned down settlements up there.
You also is more than happy to turn a
blind eye to crime outside my
jurisdiction.
That is until he owes you a favor.
Then there's Mr.
West Dickens,
the snake oil salesman,
businessman,
and a harmless old fraud kind of man
that built this country,
a man who actively discourages people
from acting selflessly and uses Marston
to when horse racists and sell his tonic
before lending a helping hand or
professor McDougall,
the anthropologist from an Ivy League
school who also happens to be a racist
cocaine addict whose theories on
genealogy are constantly proven wrong.
It's remarkable.
It completely refute my last book with
allies like these were forced to ask
who's the good guy?
You've probably heard the phrase history
is written by the victors and red dead
redemption seems to agree the federal
marshals like Johnson are ultimately the
ones who tamed the wild west.
Professor Mcdougall,
who believed the native Americans to be
barely human savages survives to bring
these stories back to civilization where
the decimation of native tribes
continued for decades,
Wild West Dickens,
the entrepreneur and profiteer lives to
sell another bottle of Elixir.
These dick bags were the real champions
of the wild west.
The idealist die while the cunning
shysters survive,
such as rockstar satire of the old West
as a post western red dead,
not only satirizes the western genre,
but the history of the West itself.
The game takes place at the beginning of
the 20th century when the old lawless
west was dying,
killed off by industrialization and
urban development.
Federal law was growing to help police
these newer states and the industrial
revolution was finally catching up with
western expansion.
We'd like to think that this
technological progress tamed the Wild
West,
but the game points out that it just
brings its own flavor of violence.
It gives you a railroad that you can
take anywhere,
but as Marshall Johnson points out,
the owners burned down people's houses.
You're also given an early machine gun
twice that you use to gun down entire
rvs.
Not exactly your mythic cowboys,
shootouts,
but equally,
if not more violent,
but hey,
new technology is awesome.
Socialization is a truly beautiful
thing.
Mr Marsden,
you end up with a pretty nuanced debate
about the merits of civilization.
Just as technology came to civilize the
west,
so did the government,
which is similarly not given a
flattering portrayal.
For example,
Abraham Reyes stages a coup against the
dope,
botched and cruel colonel.
Again,
day in Mexico before we meet him.
Reyes is described as a heroic
revolutionary leader of great moral
work.
He doesn't care for the bourgeois
snobbery or elitism
when we do meet him.
However,
he's a lying,
arrogant,
selfish womanizer who isn't stirring up
revolution to free Mexico,
but to get money in power with no
intention of leading once it's attained
like any great leader,
my brother I will delegate.
The other representative of government
is Edgar Ross.
You know the US official who has the
backing of the US government so he can
civilize the west.
Well,
he forces you to murder your former
friends by stealing your family.
We need you to find them.
Williamson then had to blackwater as
quick as you can,
and we have reason to believe that Dr
van Dolson does in the area or your wife
sends her regards
and when you accomplish your goal,
since the entire army to your house to
shoot you to pieces even says,
see we,
me and archer,
we're the bad guys.
We enforce the rules.
This is a world where the good guys call
themselves bad guys and the bad guys
think they're good guys.
So if the game is targeting the people
who built the institutions that survive
today,
isn't that kind of bleak?
Well,
Rockstar may not be full of quite as
many edge lords as it seems as their
conclusion on the merits of civilization
is quite complex.
So sure,
John Marsden and Co argue that while
life is an outlaw is violent and often
ugly,
they are at least free,
but the feds point out that the cowboys
violence that comes from defending their
freedom kinda sucks for everyone else.
I'll tell you what the alternative is.
It's not complicated.
It's about one man and his gun versus
another man.
Sure,
civilization may be dull,
but the alternative Mr Marsden is hell.
This bleak satire of society can be
summed up in the chief antagonist of the
game.
Dutch band,
Holland.
Dutch is the former leader of Marston's
old gang and the man you're sent to
kill,
but he isn't quite a classic Western
billing.
We hear from Marston how Dutch raised
him.
Leader of the gang taught me how to
read.
He taught me how to see all that was
good in the world.
It was a great man in a way,
and
whenever we meet Dutch,
he's eloquent and honest.
Violent,
sure,
but isn't everyone in this game.
And then there's the fact that his new
posse consists almost entirely of
disenfranchised native Americans who see
Dutch as a savior.
The only native American character who
talks to Marston and his allies is
nastiness,
is patronized and insulted by Professor
Mcdougall and then shot in the head is a
trader by his own people.
Dutch is trying to stand against the
march of the so called civilization of
the West.
That Marston's mission represents having
seen what it does to people in their
communities before Dutch dies.
He says,
when I'm gone,
they'll do is find another monster.
Yeah,
because they have to justify their wages
for Dutch.
If you want an industrialized military
with machine guns and motorcars,
you need to justify that investment with
an enemy to use it against,
which makes his character of less an
oblique satire and more of an on the
nose commentary,
seeing as it would only be three years
later,
that world war one would break out in
red dead redemption,
not only as our nostalgic view of the
old west wrong,
but so is the idea that the civilization
that replaced it is somehow better.
We're left with a world in which the
crooked businessmen,
selfish revolutionaries,
morally bankrupt,
academics and corrupt government
officials are the ones laying the
building blocks of the new world.
While the selfless are forgotten.
With this kind of pessimism running
through the game,
it's no wonder a key mantra throughout
his
erase your past Mr.
Marsden
and that
you can erase the past.
Come won't make it go away
and
he's old.
That's it.
CanNot be nice.
Just as John can't escape his violent
past,
neither can America.
Thanks for sticking around.
Guys were very excited to unveil the
first of our mini sites that we designed
using wix.
We're currently doing a full overhaul of
our main website and it's going to be
awesome,
but we wanted to get some new features
rolled out as soon as possible.
I'm not the most savvy guy with
computers,
so I was really pleased with how robust
and professional wix site building tools
where it's nice when you have an idea in
your head on how something should look
and the technology you're using gives
you the options to make it happen
without the hassle.
So whether you're a seasoned pro or a
total newb like me,
if you're thinking about building or
upgrading the website,
I encourage you to check out what you
can do with wix and in the meantime,
head over to our site,
linkedin,
the description,
and let us know what you'd like us to
cover in an upcoming episode of.
Show me the meeting and as always,
guys,
thanks for watching.
Peace.